American fashion designer Rick Owens has
he's trying to change fashion and it's
involving the penis that's right we've
got a couple images of what he's been up
to lately he is sending men down the
catwalk with clothes that are showing
off just a wee bit bit of the penis so
there you go yeah this is actually a
thing this guy truck nuts in fashion
just like we've seen truck mats I don't
know what trucks or people to the bat
truckers and people that have trucks
that was like Midwest in the South but
tie these things that look like balls to
hang down from the back of the license
plate underneath the truck I mean coat
truck nuts so it looks basically like
this is like fashion meets truck nuts
so finally the high fashion elite of New
York is meeting up with the Midwest in
order to present fashion yeah this seems
utterly like how much of this fashion
stuff I don't know much about fashion
you are a fashionista are you not you
know everything there is so this is so
crazy first of all when women say
they're fashionistas I immediately think
I don't know what to do with you and I
probably don't like it which sounds
terrible so I somehow accidentally for a
little while was a stylist and did
on-air styling for personalities and
represented fashion brands but with all
that said I and even though I like
clothes I think fashion is the stupidest
thing ever so I think maybe what Rick
Owens was doing here was doing what
everyone should do which is make a
little bit of fun of fashion and just
have fun with it
you can't take fashion too seriously so
why not just have dicks coming down the
runway like that's just perfect this is
the best fashion moment I think he's
having fun with this or he just wants
people to talk because I think that's a
lot yeah so Rick Owens has always been
known for being very fashion-forward so
you know those pants you've seen they're
kind of like harem pants or have like
the drop crotch pants that have been
around me I think 2008 is when you first
design them right Rick Owens has been
known for kind of pushing the envelope
particularly with men and using some
silhouettes that could be considered
feminine or just do kind of very high
fashion for the average guy to be
wearing so I think that to push the
envelope a little bit further would just
be to do something that gets everyone's
attention right it hadn't been born of
an accident like someone was putting on
a shirt or a thing and make you so they
saw they're you know there's just enough
of your foreskin down there yeah we can
make it trendy I think he's being silly
I think he's trying to get attention I
love it just because fashion is so
stupid or taking
fashion seriously but how about that I
love clothes I like shopping I go
fashionista
I just watched Devil Wears Prada the
other day hi Miranda Priestly said that
fashion is very very important right
which should of course tell you
immediately how unimportant oh right so
you don't think we're gonna be seeing
the the balls hanging out any hope if
you start the trend maybe I consider the
dress
this reminds me I mentioned on the show
a couple weeks ago when I was in New
York City once and there was a guy an
old guy like probably a 70 singer oh man
it was the heat of the summer and he was
wearing short shorts and his old balls
were just hanging out we're literally on
the on the chair I don't think you know
I don't I think he had old deflated
balls deflated balls are very popular
right now that's a lot they with 40
things so we're not gonna see it played
about I mean you want the balls to be
seen but you know I mean you I think
maybe some hardcore fashion people and
I'm so serious might take this seriously
and not understand he clearly was just
trying to you know drive a little bit of
press towards his brand but you know I
don't fight anymore I won't come with
you pick out I don't care do it go what
that's you know the vagina is the vagina
gonna be hanging the joints got a lot of
attention with like vajazzling or for
jeiza laying yes I think look the beef
gets a lot more attention I think you
know especially in pop culture world so
it's this is the year of the dick guys
if you were to hear first is this the
year of the dick let us know in the
comments below and